um i didn't know what is happening over
there
what the [ __ ]
ruining my crystals
what the [ __ ]
use this in the intro
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to big mood
we got the whole gang here it's nikki
gang [ __ ]
that was gina and i am jess yes
everybody is here maybe you know us by
now maybe you don't maybe you're new
well this week's episode you're gonna
get to know us i feel like we know each
other pretty well but i started playing
this game called we're not really
strangers not sponsored but they make
this game that's built to like have
deeper conversations with people in your
life yeah whether you just met them
whether you're on a date it could be a
good like conversation starter if you're
on a date uh steve and i actually did it
on our podcast that they don't tell you
because they have different decks like
they have one for friends one for
relationship um and we did a
relationship one and we talked really
deep all the time but we got even deeper
reading some of these questions so they
have a free version online maybe we'll
include it in the description if you
want to check it out but i pulled some
questions from the friendship deck
and let's see if we can learn some new
stuff about each other okay there's
three levels to the game the first level
is perception
the second level wait hold on i was
organizing now i'm not the second level
is um connection and then the third
level is
reflection okay so we're gonna get to
know each other on all three levels and
we're gonna begin round one and pass
around the phone um this first round
you're gonna read the question in front
of you and then everybody else is gonna
answer it about you okay uh if you get a
red card on your turn it's kind of like
a wild card and all of us answer and
then you can read the next one so that
doesn't count as your turn oh okay okay
tipponi you want to start okay
so when i read this you guys are
answering this about me yes yes okay
what does my style tell you about me
your style yeah my style i think that it
tells me that you're very
you take a lot of time to consider what
you're doing
and you're also very clean
and tidy
and
girly yeah you already put together you
have charlotte from sex and the city
vibes to me yeah yeah you're very
ladylike and you accessorize and i
remember
um the first you know well not the first
few times but then like many times when
i'm hanging out with you i was like wow
people actually accessorize yeah i need
to get my [ __ ] i can't do that to save
my life you exude feminine energy yeah
yeah cool yeah you're good at colors
like this necklace that i'm wearing the
only reason why i'm wearing is because i
put it on once and just never took it
off because
yeah you have like a certain you'll pick
jewelry for each outfit hairstyles for
each house
[Applause]
because i totally don't do any of that
yes you do you'll you'll come and pick
like jewelry you've done that done in
front of me at least yeah yeah you're
like no
photo shoots yeah yeah but for the most
part actually i don't i really don't but
i feel like for the most part like we're
at home when our pajamas [ __ ] off
like all the time
we're all equals at home but like your
style i feel like is what you present to
the world that's awesome because it's
like i'm a liar
because i don't i'll just like pick one
pair of earrings and wear them for weeks
and same with the necklace and then
you're like oh it's different uh what is
it hairstyles
i just get out of the shower
that's it
you make it look effortless okay yeah
that's awesome that's so sweet and then
also i love how you said that about when
you met me that you're like people
actually accessorize because when we met
the first thing i remember is you
gifting me a ring
oh love language i probably wore it for
like weeks i'm like your ticket
like i don't
okay gina you're next oh you just swipe
i swipe yeah swipe to the left or to the
right uh to the left
okay
uh what is the first thing you noticed
about me
oh the first thing i noticed because
that was years ago yeah yeah yeah
i try to remember when you're really oh
you're really pretty and you're a lot
more gentle than i thought you yeah i
remember
yeah having that thought that's true
because i had only seen you in like
thumbnails of jk videos where it's like
uh sex what was it sex something like
big boobies
ask this expert or whatever and i was
like oh okay she's gonna be a baddie
like she's gonna be like really like
over the top on it like energy wise i
hadn't watched the videos of you and i
just like just based off of the gina
darling video thumbnails i was like i
kind of get an idea of what she'll be
like and then the first time i met you i
feel like it was in vegas right in 2018
i think so the vegas trip and
you were so
no 2000 yeah early it was early 2017.
yeah
yeah i mean we had
maybe maybe we were at jacobs and i
don't feel like we were in a jk episode
vegas was the first time we actually
like interacted interactive yeah like
craps
yeah
and you were just like so gentle you
totally reminded me of my best friend
from high school just like a free spirit
i thought you were more of a like
i mean
i mean you are a gamer bad badass chick
but i thought you were more like um
more like that like just hard right yeah
more prickly yeah because i actually i
remember having the same thought but um
for different reasons because i didn't
know of you until we met face to face
but just
meeting you face to face
without speaking yet because we hadn't
spoken to each other yet because we uh
we were there to film a skit
so you were interacting with other
people
and
i just immediate i'm so used to coming
like especially like in high school and
stuff i'm so used to meeting like really
beautiful girls that end up being really
stuck up
and really like kind of [ __ ] and like
they'll they'll be they'll kind of act
like oh you're like i'm you're my
competition or something with me so i'm
like i just got used to like getting
that from really pretty girls
so i was ready for like i was bracing
for that from you and you were so
[ __ ] sweet yeah like so like
warm and inviting like i said you gave
me a ring where i was like
holy [ __ ] like totally not what i was
expecting
but yeah like you you had the same
thought like you're so gentle
stop it you guys yeah
i'm trying to keep it right i'm sorry
she's a bet she's bad i have a brand
she's very cold she's cold she's
starting to break through lots of water
first of all when i meet him i punch him
okay i don't know well she punched me in
and then we were friends yeah and then
she was really gentle
i'm trying to remember because i met you
a long time ago i remember we were both
at uh barton joe's wedding in hawaii
like many many years ago
and but we just never really interacted
for a lot of years and then we went
shopping together one time like randomly
several years ago
and i'm trying to remember like i just
remember you being super helpful and
like but what did i notice about you i
don't know that's a hard question i'm on
do i not notice things about people
right away because that's just that was
the first interesting many many years
yeah i don't know i didn't
i didn't it definitely was never
negative so i don't know it's just not
standing out it's like something crazy
you're not memorable to me no i'm just
kidding i think it's just like there was
just not we didn't have a lot of
interactions for a long time but you're
just always there like gina was always
there but just so far away yeah that i
didn't ever really get an impression
really like yeah i think like you it
took me and you a long time to have like
like a connection or a friendship yeah
because you were always like joe's
girlfriend and then i was just always
just like randomly around yeah sort of
there but like not super involved at
least not with me and joe that much yeah
so yeah so that day when you're like
just go shopping i was like oh ooh it's
a chance to make friends and i was like
i really need help shopping like
please help me because i go to the mall
all the time and i literally leave with
nothing i'm like i can't figure out what
to buy and i was born and i think i
still left with nothing that yeah
because it was just so difficult
to be honest with you i didn't really
give a [ __ ] about shopping that day i
was just like i'm going to make a friend
that's cute
yeah
i actually really had a great time and
we had that
dinner or whatever in the mall that was
enjoyable i mean yeah it was always
enjoyable but nothing was like this and
then it was actually that like it was
just like a slow burn for us i think
yeah
i think i get that a lot of people are
like you look a lot meaner than you
actually are yeah well you have like an
edgier uh
persona like an image of online image
yeah from just pictures like not
necessarily when you start talking and
right yes you're really easy to get
along with like
i'm just very soft to my friends i need
to start being weird okay here we go
live up to my expectation
your phone
actually punch me yeah
i'm offended you haven't punched me yet
it's like you don't even like me
i feel like i should have been stabbed
by now
it hasn't happened
we'll get there gina one day
what the heck
okay this is weird if you were to buy me
a present knowing nothing about me other
than what i look like what would it be
oh
that's amazing a smile mason jars
because i'm white
[ __ ]
would you see it honestly i was like a
smile
[Laughter]
honestly i'm really not a gift person
i'm like don't [ __ ] give me [ __ ] cuz
i'm not getting you [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
drag me into this gift giving [ __ ]
cycle of hell i don't like this question
next one yeah i don't like it
yeah
you're not a present person yeah well no
we're supposed to look at her just from
like what she looks like
what would you what would you buy me
just looking at me it's hard because i
know you too much
like just looking at you a pack of
cigarettes
hollywood glamour like you just like do
i look like i smoke cigarettes
like you just look like you remind me of
like an old hollywood like a long
cigarette like
long one no the one that's like
holder like a breakfast tiffany so that
you don't get the smoke smell on your
fingers yeah like you're a fancy feed
away from you
actually i get like i get like what the
opposite like just by looking at you
it's the opposite of like me knowing you
yeah oh really so i look like what i'm
really fancy yeah we know you're trying
to look like you're not getting that so
what would you buy me just looking at so
for you i see you being like super
actually more like nikki's personality
is like like what you so bullet journal
feel like like physically you would
write a journal like super
super girly like i don't know like
starbucks loving yeah like a basic [ __ ]
yeah
i do like starbucks starbucks tumblr
yeah so you know those gift packs that
you buy was just like it has like lotion
and i was thinking that like something
you're gonna give me some [ __ ]
soap basket yeah because we get a free
tote but if you just never if you've
never opened your mouth just yeah it
would see it would seem like you would
love it you would appreciate it you'd be
so happy to receive that gift yeah but
you open your mouth and you ruin it
we don't know you're like a
fancy car loving freak a fancy car
loving freak i am a fancy car i know but
we don't know that from looking at you
so i mean looking at me you should know
that you should just buy me a bmw
nothing else that's the only gift
people saw that in me getting a juicy
sweatpants
actually you know you know angelina
jolie and mr mrs smith like her
vibe like corporate world vibe
beautiful really classy put together
like enjoys a glass of wine at home kind
of [ __ ] that's what you look like but
i'm totally not a wine drinker or any of
them i know that's based on what you
look like yeah yeah that's funny yeah so
like mouth closed wine mouth open palm
malls oh god
they're serious
my dad smokes a cigarette it's a [ __ ]
old-ass brand throwback
i've never even heard of that brand yeah
yeah me neither all right do i remind
you of anyone
megan batoon
really
[Applause]
that's funny i mean i got it she's half
filipino halfway and also just like
really creative really pretty has really
good with uh hobbies uh what's it called
home decor
yeah
we do have a lot of similar interests
that's true yeah i'll take it i'll take
it as a compliment yeah i mean you look
like sure for sure you all have the same
dna and you know shout out to megan
mattoon check her out um but she
actually we're the same mixture of half
filipino like most people have a
filipino mom and a white dad but we had
filipino dads and white mom yeah so
that's why y'all are kind of similar i
think because there's plenty of like
mixed filipino people but y'all are like
very similar i think it's that yeah same
dna breakdown
that must be it i don't really pay
attention to people outside of my circle
so you just remind me of nikki
there's only one of you in my life
that's just from like an outside fan
perspective but like internally i don't
think you're like anyone else that i
that i know or
remind
you actually do remind me of it's a tv
show character it's
lily from how i met your mother oh
you're so like her in like personality
wise because like she's an art teacher
you're very creative yeah she she always
busts people's balls like in the friend
group and you you're really funny i
never do that you really do that um oh
and then also like her relationship with
marshall is so you and steve that's true
it's so you and i was on how i met your
mother
it was a really small role and they
actually cut most of my roll out what
season
it was epis uh season 8 episode 4 i
think it was called who wants to be a
godparent
and i'm at the very very very end like
the button of the episode um
and i basically call out um what's his
face neil patrick kerris yeah his
character
barney barney i call him out because
he's trying to like pretend he has a
baby um to see women's breath he has a
camera on the stroller so they bend over
to see the baby and like their boobs
yeah and then i call him out on his like
thing and that's that was my whole line
oh cool yeah you remind me of me now
that we've gotten to know each other
that's true similar that's why you
remember my best friend from high school
um okay oh you got a wild card oh me
what does that mean yeah that's like i
think everyone participates okay so it
says think of your favorite childhood tv
show of all time on the count of three
say it out loud tv show of all time my
favorite childhood tv childhood tv show
childhood tv show i don't have three
seconds i need like longer than three
let's sink and then we'll say yeah okay
i'm too old for three seconds hold on i
gotta go way back in the roller deck i
think i got mine okay ready
three
two
one all that
i was always a sketch person i watched
all that and then i graduated to mad tv
and as i graduated well and then and
then in living color oh yeah
all of the sketch stuff i actually liked
mad tv more than snl yeah i liked the
living color the most though yeah as a
kid but for as far as child childish tv
shows all that i guess yeah all that for
sure which one is yours sailor moon
mine it was really hard to to think of
one because like when there's so many my
mind just goes blank so i'm like okay
that's the first one i thought
no it's a spanish variety show oh okay
yeah which one did you say oh mine i
said sabrina and teenage white
i didn't love that show
have you seen it lately because that
animatronic [ __ ]
catalyst disgusting why didn't we like
it so much i know it doesn't look that
crazy to me i was obsessed as a kid with
wanting powers like
like matilda is like that's true
matilda and canada hat with mike myers
those are my two most favorite movies
and but matilda when i was little i'd be
there like [ __ ] trying to move my
cheerio too
[ __ ] your parents like this is weird
you've been trying to be a witch for a
long time
or like i'd be sitting on the toilet in
a public restroom and like i'd be like
tapping tiles in different like ways
because i'm like this is gonna unlock a
portal somewhere i swear
but i like sabrina the teenage witch
because i loved melissa joan hart's
personality yeah i just like thought she
was just the coolest yeah and you know
what recently i went on twitter and i
was like what's she up to she follows me
yeah i was like so i followed her back
immediately
oh my
her and then that was like she was a
little older for me because that was in
the like younger i get well the same age
but like for me like that show was
already like it already ended it's true
it was even a little older for me yeah
but i i liked watching this was cool and
then um she was in a britney video she
was in crazy yeah she found out that
they were friends
and then she was in can't hardly wait
the movie i was just talking to you
about with jennifer love hewitt she was
the yearbook girl oh no yeah that name
is so long right i love her so much but
you know what else i love what is
receiving food straight to my door
thanks to doordash yeah yeah just let us
know the best friend in clarissa
explains it all has a letter to go
straight through
to her life yeah so shout out to our
sponsor doordash doordash connects you
with the restaurants you love right now
and right to your door and now you can
get grocery essentials you need with
doordash
you can get drinks snacks and other
household items delivered in under an
hour and ordering is super easy just
open the doordash app you choose what
you want from where you want and your
items will be left safely outside your
door with the contactless delivery
drop-off setting with over 300 000
partners in the us puerto rico canada
and australia
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like wednesdays
wednesdays
and cheesecake factory thank you gina
and nikki
or whataburger
yeah no i mean it is probably
like we've actually so for these shoot
days we've been using doordash to
to deliver some food for our lunch so
we're absolutely fans over here and for
a limited time our listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood that's 25 off up to a 10 value and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code mode don't
forget that's code mood for 25 off your
first order with doordash subject to
change
terms apply
and while we're on these shoots we like
comfort food and we like to feel
comfortable in our bras and underwear
third love creates high quality
underwear sleep and loungewear
delivering life-changing comfort your
body loves being in i personally have
so many third love bras and that's the
only type of bra i like anymore it it's
because it doesn't even feel like i'm
wearing a bra it i never had a bra that
actually fit my breasts before i always
thought that they were supposed to have
a gap or like they just they fall off
your shoulder it just happens like that
yeah um i didn't know what is happening
over there
what the
use this in the intro
i leaned back
what you queef
wait what
you leaned back
and she hit your belly
keep doing it you gotta go
keep on keeping her up real hard
[Laughter]
made a drum beat like it went through my
intestines and came back
oh my goodness
put that back no you slid it back
down crystal it's gonna start shedding
again oh god shutting your demonic
energy bring good arms
oh my god
okay yeah i thought the straps would
fall are supposed to fall off your
shoulder eventually that's just part of
having a bra but it don't have to be
that way you can actually get a bra that
fits your body and your breast disease
get the level of fit and comfort you
deserve with third love bras underwear
and loungewear find your new favorite
holiday essentials from loungewear to
their number one rated 24 7 classic
t-shirt bra you also like can't see it
underneath your shirt which i really
like you go on there you take a fitting
room quiz they'll quiz you on like how
your current bra fits and what issues
you have with it also what your boobie
shape is and then it'll try to size you
with your perfect fit they also have
half sizes which is really cool they
have so many sizes too so like you're
definitely going to find a bra that fits
your body they stand behind their
products if you don't love it exchanges
and returns are free third love knows
you deserve to feel comfortable and
confident 24 7. so right now they're
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order go to thirdlove.com big mood now
to find your perfect fitting bra and get
20 off your first purchase that's
thirdlove.com big mood for 20 off today
did we finish answering the last one oh
we were talking about the tv shows oh
yeah yeah we did it okay
oh yeah melissa john hart let's go come
on big move girl we love you got lots of
fans here all right now we move on to
level two this level is all about
connection okay so with this level
you're going to read the question and
you're going to answer it about yourself
and then we can like talk about it
afterwards but you answered about
yourself okay i go again i did the wild
card yeah okay when you're asked how are
you how often do you answer truthfully
oh that's a good one
because you seem like a person that'd be
like oh i'm i'm fine
oh i feel i mean
it's kind of hard to know like about
your own self
i personally feel like
depending on who it is i'll answer
truthfully
and
most and then so it would be people that
i'm really close to and i almost always
only speak to people that i'm really
close to so i feel like i almost always
usually answer truthfully mm-hmm
so that makes sense yeah cause like you
know in like my dark times when i was
really like yeah
not in a good place i had
no matter how hard like i wanted to try
to hide it i couldn't hide it and we'd
go into like
convos i'm like [ __ ] and then you're
so guilty that you were jumping on
people i really felt bad yeah so you do
always answer truthfully which you
weren't by the way but like you weren't
dumping on people but um you weren't
doing it but i was like i'm sorry you
weren't really depressed especially
because i had
like friends before telling me like you
know you just you're always so negative
like every time we talk it's always
about your problems and i'm like
[ __ ] yeah sorry me too so i'm like
that's what makes people just answer i'm
fine right yeah exactly
so i learned like okay with you in
particular i can't be myself
because then like i'll get judged for it
i think that's fair like you don't want
to
dump your problems on someone that
doesn't really care about you so like
someone that's not your close friend
like i can see just being like yeah
everything's cool or even if you're a
close friend you know they're not
someone that can
handle your emotions yeah because like
i've even dated guys like they can't
handle my emotions like i can't be
honest at all all day i have to just be
fake and it's like oh no that's supposed
to be someone really close to me but
yeah exactly because this person was
really close to me too but i'm like oh
[ __ ] i guess
okay i didn't know i was ruining your
day like this i'm so sorry some people
can get others emotions and like
they can like just talk about it and
they don't absorb your energy or like
your problems but other people
they will absorb your energy they'll
absorb your problems it'll stress them
out so it's just maybe just a difference
in personality it is but yeah yeah i do
absorb people's energies and problems
but if i am given a heads up i can like
kind of block it from happening first
before we start talking deep so
if it starts off like
well actually then i'm like okay let me
put my walls up first hold on because
otherwise i'm just gonna feel all the
pain and it'll last for a week yeah i
think you do answer yeah all right jenna
okay
wild card
call someone you admire and tell them
why you appreciate them put them on
speakerphone
what do we admire or who do you admire
oh yeah this is a question yeah [ __ ]
who do you admire yeah who do i admire
no one i can call my phone
watch my phone rings
sorry but probably not yeah right gina
right
you're about to call my phone nicki is
hoping that you call her phone right now
and you put me on speakerphone
i'm thinking of someone you might agree
with do you know i'm trying to facetime
the three of you stupid [ __ ]
who do you actually admire yeah let me
see do you admire someone that you yeah
be real um let me see [ __ ] i just
answered you
could i admire
i or i don't know about admirer but the
one i know who okay yeah
let me see all right let's see
uh my stepmom
i really admire her a lot because
i have never met a person
so patient in my whole entire life so
i'm going to facetime her
and we're gonna we're gonna
what she does hi mom
we're recording an episode of big mom
big mood big mom big mom big momma
you're my girl hey
hi
say hi mom hi mom we're playing a game
and my card that i pulled was uh call
someone who you admire and put them on
speakerphone
okay and i just want to tell you i
admire you because you're the most
you're the most patient woman that i
know and i i love you a lot
i love you too gina oh
he cry god dude you did soft ass [ __ ]
okay i love you
i love you too say bye bye mom
okay bye mom
bye sweetie
oh that was
the most patient woman in the world the
biggest heart very selfless and just
like so chill she and i became like best
friends yeah i love that yeah like how
long ago did you meet her step mom uh i
want to say 11 years ago okay yeah
that's like during your formative yeah
you're finding your identity type of
years yeah so when we oh wait oh that
was wildcard i'm supposed to like
actually oh yeah i forgot it could be
just a personal one so whenever we she
picks me up from the airport we just
hang out like she's one of those mom so
it's like don't tell dad i smoke
cigarettes and we'll stop by the side of
the road smoking cigarettes and then
spare yourself a perfume down afterwards
she's my best friend i love her
um let's see have you ever told someone
i love you but didn't mean it if so why
that's a good one no
no no no not really uh
yeah no i'm i kind of don't really you
know like i mean i'll i'll say it like
if i like when i threatened my nurses
like i love you
stay back wait so you were the story of
that as you were going under on right so
i was when i got my boobs done recently
um the nurses called me up afterwards
you know after my surgery and they're
like do you remember what you said right
before you passed out from the
anesthesia like no they were like you
were you kept telling us that you loved
us and then you popped your head up and
said say it back
you did that in another episode oh like
what was that you were talking to bryce
or something it was it was the um it was
the catching up episode yeah yeah so i
do that a lot oh you mean
she did it like she said during our yeah
yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah
say it back even when i say it's like i
i think i just have a lot of love to
give so just like i do love these people
around me you know yeah it's just like a
little bit of love it's not doesn't mean
that i'm like in love with you right you
know but there's a little bit of love
that i try to share with everyone
absolutely yeah yeah i don't really say
it without
not without meaning it or unless it's
like
like this yeah really it's a confetti
yeah i love you
or like if this question means like in a
relationship when a guy says it to me i
never say it back just to say it back
yeah how do you dodge that yeah i'm
really honest about it i'm like oh
thanks i'm just not there yet or if it's
later on the relationship it's just like
uh let's talk about god that has never
happened yeah holy so i'm i'm pretty
honest with my love does that happen to
you jess i feel like because i've been
in a lot of i've had well i've had a
couple of normal boring relationships
but i had a couple of really crazy ones
too and like when they try to get back
with me after kind of really [ __ ] me
over and they're like but i love you and
i'm like
i love you too but i'm like confused
about it i'm like i think i do but then
later on i'm like no i maybe i don't i
don't know sometimes i'm like i don't
know do i i can't i can't tell if i do i
don't know like it's hard it's if you
don't know you probably don't well but
maybe you
love them but like you can't love it
yeah it can get confusing for sure
saying i love you people care about
different things and
sometimes like you don't want to not say
it back because you know that it'll hurt
them and you don't like hate them so
it's like yeah i love you too but like i
have love for you yeah okay yeah that's
weird but yeah i don't i definitely
don't go around like telling people i
love them when i don't all the time and
yeah that's probably like a really
difficult situation that i was in or
something yeah i really hard to that
especially like
like previous relationships like when i
already oh exactly what you how you
described it like i'm with this person
i'm supposed to like still kind of like
love you i think i do i don't know i
care about you like if you died today
right now i'd be devastated yeah so i'm
like does that mean that i love you like
it's really confusing so i'm like
yeah i love you too i guess like i i
really don't know yeah
yeah it's hard to know what love even
means sometimes yeah
so wow that's deep
[ __ ] i'm
how deep are you
okay
um
are you missing anyone right now do you
think they are missing you too
um
if i'm missing anyone right now
the only person that pops up in my head
is my mom
huh
and she's passed away so
i said i wasn't going to cry the first
one to cry
[ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] solid as a rock i never cry
and
that one [ __ ] hit me
do you believe in
like the after
i don't know sometimes i do and
sometimes i'm like nah does it comfort
you to think that she might be out there
thinking of you or does it make you sad
um
probably makes it a little worse because
i feel like she might regret her life so
much and like i don't want her to like
feel bad about it to continue to have
regrets so like sometimes it would
almost be better for her to like just
cease to exist but then also i don't
know like even if you do cross over
um if you like learn so much that you
cease to regret yeah then that would be
more comforting if you learn like if you
get all of like the universe's
information and you cease to regret and
that would be obviously helpful too
because both are freedom you just don't
want to feel trapped anywhere yeah yeah
yeah oh just
um okay well i'm not gonna cry because
i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
out of all people making the last one
crying yeah
i think he should have already cried by
him what's happening i put on my walls
i'm not gonna feel your pain i'm gonna
feel the sadness
um when's the last time you felt lucky
to be you
oh wow
uh yeah no when you got married
no you're with us right now because
we're awesome i okay so this is weird
because like i do feel like super
grateful for my life like i'm like wow
like
if you if i was picking my life from
like before i got to earth you know they
were like you're gonna live in this
house in l.a you're gonna have this
group of friends and you're gonna be
married to this guy that really loves
you and like this job and like you're
it's so fulfilling and that's like oh my
god dream life like i i am so grateful
but
yeah i don't know i've always had a
problem with like beating myself up and
not thinking that
i'm not thinking that i'm doing enough
like that i'm like contributing enough
to the world i don't know if like
huh dad that's really hard because like
i don't feel like i don't know if i'm
lucky to be me
i guess i yeah i don't know there's i
think everyone like is going to have a
lot of really bad [ __ ] happen to them so
it's easy to be like oh i never get like
woes me about yeah no yeah it's it's
very common though to be like yes
there's been a lot of bad [ __ ] so it's
been a while since i've felt good or at
least yeah i guess like i am
but the feeling of gratitude does feel
lucky because i'm like of all the
positions i could possibly be in first
world like all that yeah like i feel
incredibly lucky to be in in
this position that i am now i'm lucky
that you're you
no
cute that's cute so cute i'm stopping a
softie
[Laughter]
yeah i guess i i mean i keep a gratitude
journal there we go every day then the
answer is every day every [ __ ]
day and i don't cry and i
don't at me
that's right i'm gangster with my
answers okay uh mine says
if you could have it your way who would
you want to be with wait wait sorry let
me say it again
be honest
it's my freaking dyslexia it's been
getting worse it's like a pregnancy
brain yeah
it's like words are like
a few brain cells you have left out here
okay it says if you could have it your
way who would you be with
what who would you be with am i reading
this right if you could have it your way
who would you be with where would you be
and what would you be doing so your your
ideal day because i can't help but think
of the relationship yeah who are you
like you're like i chose that i'm
married what do you mean what do you
mean in your perfect day like if you
were envisioning a perfect day who's
with you where are you
and what would you be doing
oh man
wow if you could casey plug your ears
because she's gonna be like nikki
um
oh for a thousand percent it would be on
a tropical beach yeah not some italy
[ __ ] water beach i don't think you
don't i don't think you have to pick
just one person because it's like who
would you be with you could be with like
yeah a group of people
as long as it's us i for sure thought of
a group if it's a group that's not us
then they can go [ __ ] right off yeah so
you can also [ __ ] right off let's answer
this truthfully yeah i know your pieces
filled with needles
[Laughter]
or at least like dirty rusty needles
you're going to get stung by man or
jellyfish if you answer it don't you
want to be with us i'm like i'm like
intercepting your dream because i'm not
trying to get what we're doing
because like oh man like dream day
dream like experience
who's there
where are we at what are we doing i know
for a fact it would be like casey isaac
you guys
casey's family which my family um my mom
my brothers i don't want everyone to be
there my cousin jenny
um so like your wedding because yeah
because jenny wasn't there and my sister
wasn't and i wasn't there either yeah
nikki wasn't there like we weren't at
each other's weddings it's like the
to me that none of you were at my
wedding yeah and the people that were
there like most of them like i don't
know we haven't talked to in a while so
for those who don't know we weren't
there because we had just barely met her
yeah because we didn't want to yeah me
and gina like i said 2018 we got married
in 2017. yeah
no and then uh so it's like the most
important people
in my life
um and having all of us be at a tropical
beach yes enjoying the water
i also don't have photo sensitivity so i
could be enjoying the sun
um and could i not get sunburned too can
steve and the ice machine also be there
sure steve can be used
with your eyes bro we're in the middle
of filming stephen just give him a
warning
it's like it's really loud
he's like i didn't think it would be
that loud
um i want a steve camera for our podcast
right we have a pop-in picture in
picture that's so funny
oh but the things that we're doing
though because i want to add to it
um my own personal happiness like happy
place is like beach time but at the same
time we're like by a little airport and
every and then like there's like a plane
ride giving people skydiving um
[Music]
okay i'm gonna be on that plane and also
uh there's like jet skis and we're just
[ __ ] having a blast like that like ah
doing activities oh then ceviche is
being sued
but like the razor clams from barcelona
oh my god those are so good um and also
like sushi get married again i know gosh
yeah i think you need to redo on your
expensive ass pairs i'm down for your
actually not that expensive people think
it was very expensive it wasn't that bad
i mean i'm pretty sure i heard the price
tag and i was like okay
it was not as bad as having it here
that's it really yes oh it'll be just
because of the number of people that
it's the number of people also in the
united states they rack up the prices a
lot more because the wedding in europe
they don't do that
well this game is amazing because it
does feel a little bit like therapy
but if you really need some therapy you
can try talk space
um oh i'm over here crying about my mom
still thinking like maybe i should get a
little bit more therapy um the world's
racing to get back to normal and start
meeting up in person again but after the
year we've all had getting back to
feeling normal does still take some time
we all need help sometimes and asking
for support when you need it is actually
a sign of strength everyone thinks it
makes you weak because you need help but
actually literally everyone needs help
with talkspace you can sign up online
and start therapy in the same day you
can text video or send voice messages to
a licensed therapist so it's incredibly
convenient to have virtual sessions from
the comfort of your home
talk space is a fraction of the cost of
in-person therapy instead of waiting for
an appointment you can send unlimited
messages 24 7 and they'll engage with
you daily five days a week talkspace is
secure and private and using the latest
end-to-end bank grade encryption
technology to store client information
and complying with the latest hipaa
regulations
start feeling better with a single
message match with a licensed therapist
when you go to talkspace.com and get a
hundred dollars off your first month
with the promo code mood that's 100
off when you use the promo code mood at
talkspace.com
that's a lot of
not only should you clean up your mental
health you should also clean up your
butt butt
and with that we have hello tishi
um i you guys know that i'm a huge
advocate for bidets ever since we went
to japan uh and i feel like anyone who
doesn't have a bidet i can't be friends
with you because you have a sweaty butt
crack so keep your sweaty butt crack
clean all summer long with a brand new
hello tissue 3.0 modern bidet attachment
it's a stylish eco-friendly refreshing
little shower for your ass
hello tissue 3.0 cleans soggy butts like
a champ but it doesn't stop there it
cleans itself i thought you're gonna say
it also cleans your lips
it doesn't stop there you can take it
front to back you could aim it you can
but it also cleans itself with a smart
spray automatic self-cleaning nozzle no
one wants to work up a sweat in the
summer that's why the hella tissue bidet
attaches to your existing toilet with no
electricity or extra plumbing needed
and hello tissue cuts toilet paper use
by 80 so it'll pay for itself in just a
few months plus hello tushies got your
ass covered with a 60-day risk-free
guarantee and a 12-month warranty
already got a hello tissue on the pot
treat your ass to a new 3.0 model if
you're new to the revolution join
millions of happy hello tissue customers
right now and have a clean butt with
every flush defeat swamp ass go to
hellatoshy.com big mood to get 10 off
plus free shipping this is a special
offer for our listeners at
hellotissue.com big mood for 10 percent
off again that's hellotishie.com
big mood
so now we move on to level three this
one is reflection so we're going to take
what we've talked about and what we've
learned and we are going to
reflect on it and this is the one we
have in this level you read the question
and we'll answer
uh okay uh based on what you learned
about me does my social media accurately
reflect who i am why or why not
it reflects some parts of you you're
like faker
faker it's like a tiny little portion of
the pie
okay yeah yeah i feel like child gina
dreamed up social media gina
and it's a part of you because it lives
in you and it's like
out of you created it and but it's like
it's like a playland like you have
a dream job of playing games and you
genuinely like playing video games
but like it's like an extended version
you know like you get to be
like this sexy also like yeah like
yeah yeah how cute you can tell yeah
you're like a character like you know
because like you like the anime
characters
like the badass [ __ ] characters that
they draw up and like the black and the
the knives and all that [ __ ] but like in
your daily life you're not like
switchblading people you know like yeah
you're like cuddled up with the cats
yeah yeah yeah
it's true taking naps that's true oh
that's really cute the way you put it i
kind of made up my own little superhero
yeah
yeah every time you repost like other
badass women i'm like that's you too
girl
[Laughter]
oh these guys i like these
oh [ __ ]
this one says what do i need to hear
right now
you are loved yes you're doing great i
know you have friends you [ __ ]
you know it cerebrally but you need to
feel it that i'm loved yeah i think i
believe that
um do you feel like a warm hug or do you
like just kind of know it
what do you mean do you feel like the
the like the love like do you feel the
warm
the warmth of like
if you needed anything at any time
there's like a warm feeling when you
think of people who you could reach out
to a warm feeling yeah
i guess i don't know
what that would be like
yeah because like between
you with your mom and then with the the
question about like
what is love you know
i feel like
you need that to feel yeah i mean that's
probably true and it's not
clear in my like in the forefront of my
mind
right but yeah
i don't know so you just yeah you're
left until you feel it
yeah
yeah that's that's you're probably yeah
now i'm thinking about it yeah maybe i
don't know that i am i'm like yeah
obviously i know you guys are all there
yeah like on paper but i'm still like
very far away
like even when i'm not far away from
like accepting and soaking it in like
because it doesn't ever feel like
anything different yeah from
any other time of day i don't know like
i never notice
love versus not love or like
i can't tell when it's there or when
it's not there so it's it's kind of hard
to tell that it is there does that make
sense yeah like um well the opposite of
love is fear so like
anytime you're like scared or you feel
unsupportive or there's like there's
like a lack of of ground to stand on it
is there like you you have that you do
have that yeah yeah
because sometimes i know you can get
like in that mood where you have anxiety
yeah i definitely feel like un
or unstable
in most areas of my life like even
though it's very stable and very boring
actually
everything i'm doing is like i have to
find you're trying to figure out the
most boring situation what's the most
stable that i could situation that i
could create because i've never had one
so i'm like just scrambling to do
anything you can to make it as stable as
possible
so yeah i think you're doing great at
that yeah you are
you're saying you're doing a good job
yeah well thank you and you're loved the
reason why i said you have friends [ __ ]
is because you're always like we don't
hang out we don't see each other i'm
like
but we we do
we are
i think it's the quality time thing
because like i was always alone as a
child and then i dreamed like when i
would be older that my friends would be
like a sitcom where we would see each
other every day yeah and i'm like oh
wait that's not real life
like i expected people to just come over
and they would have a key and they would
just have food and like [ __ ] would just
happen i'd be like oh okay you have a
key to our house
yeah but i don't live here anymore so
i'm too far away to just show up
but yeah so i don't know i think that's
like i've always just been like yeah i
mean i have friends but like they're
not really always around doesn't fit the
picture
yeah it doesn't fit the like when i was
a little girl i'm like okay well i'm
alone now i'm alone all day but you just
win and then but you just wait i'm gonna
have friends one day and i'm like but
then the in the real world in adult life
like people don't have time to just
always be around like that's just
hollywood
made that up the same way they make up
like
romance disney yeah that's all just
move to texas and we'll all buy houses
in a culture we'll be rich as hell i
know if y'all came out there so what's
up
a
dropping off her two kids at her
sister's house and she just drives off
oh yeah that's exactly what i would do
that's what you do yeah
just driving i'm like i know i should
say bring them to me gina but not your
kids yeah yeah
i don't have that kind of time to give
up
[Applause]
and they're watching us laughing like 10
years from now
um okay i don't know if this one's this
one's not that deep so maybe i should
skip it but it's based on what you know
about me do you have any netflix
recommendations no
next that's whack okay oh this one's
good how would you describe me to a
stranger
crystals and witchcraft and cats and and
jewelry and lots of things she likes to
do so many things all the time she does
so many things and then she cries but
she's really cute when she cries i sound
like a crackhead
and she has a nice butt her husband's
really cool and she can really decorate
and she's really smart and talented and
she's just a little bit emotionally
unstable sometimes
the person's like oh my floor's here
elevator
[ __ ] i know i describe you as like a
ball of love that's filled with anxiety
yeah that's so accurate yeah that is
exactly me and creativity yeah like
i think that's why i need the creativity
like to get all
the love and anxiety out yeah it's
creative chaos before too like the first
word that pops into my head when i think
of you is love mm-hmm
yeah you hate me
yeah like absolutely [ __ ] character
she added the anxiety and chaos
that's the mixture yeah
it's like a it's like oh it's a glowing
ball but then if you look closely it's
like really like like
those atoms are bouncing you know what i
mean like they are out there it is hot
it is very thermal
it is on fire she like
she she she loves but like she she wrote
about your love she probably cooks you
your favorite meals so she cooked about
your love she makes you a gift out of me
about your love
she'll show you how much she loves you
she'll do it in like a thousand
different ways because she has a
thousand different hobbies i'll roast
you and push all your butts yeah yeah
because i love you yeah
on you and show you how she loves you
that's so funny that's accurate
all right
okay uh this one says do you believe
everyone has a calling if so do you
think i found mine oh
no wow
most definitely not have found my
calling yet i think people have multiple
callings yeah yeah personal opinion i
think that like as you go and evolve
like your passions are allowed to change
and then like
sometimes you don't find until later in
life like something that you're actually
like really passionate about but
you're really nurturing and i think you
being pregnant right now like not that
your calling is just to be a mother but
like i feel like a lot of your
like skills and like what you're good at
is like you're nurturing and you're like
want to
help
like support a new life in the world so
maybe maybe soon
yeah i think ever since i met you you
had so many things that you wanted to do
that you've always told me about or
knowing about you know how you grew up
and how your life is it made me really
proud to see that you slowly
accomplishing all these things that you
wanted you know like
uh even if it's something you know like
decorating your house the way you want
to or going to borah traveling the world
having your dream wedding you know like
raising your kid well having your
friends and stuff like that like with
every goal that you're achieving i think
like nikki says you have so so many i
think some people have so many callings
whether small or big and you're slowly
checking everything off your list and
you're still adding more things to your
list and i think you're doing very well
oh thank you i agree with all of that
and i think you're kind of like me where
we
we were very stunted by our childhoods
yeah and so we've both struggled in like
figuring out what we're gonna do
and i think that you haven't found it
necessarily yet but like you're in in
such a better place now than you've ever
been to find it right so it's like
you've made so much growth in stride
that it's the door is just like almost
wide open but you just have to walk
through it that's the hard part because
i'm in the same position it's like i
don't [ __ ] know either yeah you know
the thing with both of you is like you
have a hard time seeing your own
strengths yeah or like
seeing your strengths as something that
that's actually like above other people
like where it's like well yeah i know
i'm good at this but like i'm not like
that's like it's not i don't know if no
one cares yeah good enough yeah like all
that internal talk yeah for sure i so
feel that yeah and i definitely feel
like like what you said like out of my
whole life i'm in the best position
right now to like
see what it is that i want to do and i
have an idea of what it is that i want
to do but it's definitely me holding
myself back because i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know if i can do this but
i'm like it's scary but
um i really think that like this thing
i'm talking about i feel like that
really is my calling yeah and it gets me
excited thinking about it and
this is a business that you can yeah
it's a business idea
um and it's not an only fan's idea and
that by the way that holding fans i did
i mentioned it a long time ago not doing
that yeah especially now you're going to
be
a mom again it's like no i mean i was
always a mom anyway yeah it's just uh
you're pregnant so it's even weirder
yeah
some people get turned on by pregnancy
yeah it's really weird but by the way it
wasn't showing my body at all on that
app anyway
this new idea this new business idea i
totally feel like
this will really make me happy and it
will help a lot of people yeah and will
make me feel really fulfilled
i'm just so scared of taking the first
step yeah like i'm scared of failure i
think because i want it so much like i
like it's so precious and i've never had
any any passion in my entire life that's
that precious that makes me this excited
like for a career that it makes me so
like i don't want to [ __ ] it up well
you're gonna [ __ ] it up i know you're
gonna learn there's no way around it
yeah but the you're looking at the whole
mountain instead of like the steps to
the mountain like yeah this is
intimidating as [ __ ] looking at the top
of the mountain but i think once you
break it down into smaller achievable
steps you're like oh [ __ ] i'm already on
this level and then like pretty soon you
go higher and higher up the mountain
you're like wow dude i know you inspire
me so much too like with all your
hobbies and like how you just make them
a reality
like so many of your hobbies have been
things that i'm like oh man i wish i
could one day learn how to do like
candle making for example i'm like [ __ ]
like i've always want to learn how to
make candles i feel like it's such a fun
thing to like just learn and do and i'm
like but i'll never be able to do that
and you're just like oh yeah i just i
had the idea yesterday and now today i'm
making my first candle i'm like that you
can do that you can do [ __ ] you can
actually follow through with [ __ ] yeah
your jewelry line and like i don't know
you're just really inspiring oh thank
you yeah i just like watch youtube
tutorials but i go down a rabbit hole
and i get like obsessed with one thing
and then i like have to do it and then
after i do it i either love it more or
i'm like okay i got that out of my
system next
i think um like i think you're like me
too or like we both expect that we have
to do something it has to be perfect the
whole way through and like if we don't
then it's like we definitely will take
that very personally and it's some sort
of weird thing where we're very
focused on ourselves so much like we
have to do everything perfect we you
know like or we can't let that that's
gonna define us like if we do it wrong
it's gonna define us then or something
like that you know i really think it's
like the trauma thing yeah where like
through childhood trauma your life was
chaos you had no control and now as an
adult we must have absolute [ __ ]
control over everything that's how we
our ocd comes out so our control
freak comes out and
yeah it's really debilitating it's like
you have to like just sit with that
dream that you have long enough to where
you're like okay i can picture it but i
can also picture like there's gonna be
like i don't know
seven [ __ ] things that that that you
know speed bumps like and then if you
can be okay with like okay there's gonna
be like seven to ten speed bumps along
the way but i still it's still worth it
to get
to the end
even though it's gonna have blemishes
and marks and yeah i'm gonna get a bad
review or something's going to happen
you know perfectionism really held me
back before and so
that's actually perfect really resonated
and i'm like so glad that that message
is resonating with other
perfectionists or like recovering
perfectionists because it can really
hinder you from taking the first step or
like or if you do do take the first step
and you think you're bad at it and
you're like oh it wasn't cut out for me
it's like no no just [ __ ] keep going
through the mistakes like
actually my acting coach helped me out
the most with that because he made me
see auditions differently i used to see
auditions as either i [ __ ] bombed it
or i did an okay mediocre job and he's
like instead of seeing it that way just
prep your auditions do everything you
can and then aft like be present in your
audition and then afterwards go over
what you think you did right what you
would like to do again like
keep doing that thing and then what you
think you could have changed and like
done better and i use the approach with
everything that i'm doing new and it
helps so much because it's like a
win-win you did one thing right and you
learn from the other thing and so it
helped both things help you up get
better
instead of seeing like one as this like
stain on your on your not realistic it's
not realistic it's not like living in
reality to think that you can do
something perfectly like i sometimes
tell me that i'm like why do i why am i
so special that i deserve to do
everything with no [ __ ] mistakes and
no like why am i like it's just like i
think that's we we have to we build our
ego in some weird way sure after that
type of trauma i think it's like our own
way of creating a sense of sense of
security yeah
but it's false yeah
it's not realistic
like if i just make everything perfect
then everything will be like no no one
can take it away yeah yeah i'll be safe
i'll be okay mm-hmm for sure
all right guys well we
got deep we learned a lot about each
other there were so many more questions
in there too on each round again yeah we
should play it again another round yeah
if you want to check it out for yourself
you want to play with your friends or
your partner
you know get some deeper conversations
specific relationship questions in this
game too there's um different decks you
can go to so there's it's we're not
really strangers online and um you can
go to the decks tab and then you can
pick like there's a politics one there's
a relationship one there's a i think
there's even a co-worker one there's
actually this is actually a physical
card game i have this game at home it's
actually physical yeah
yeah how come we never played this why
do you have this at home and we haven't
played this no no yeah what's your deal
bring your card version
better than passing around a phone
all right and then uh also if you want
to support the show go check out our
sponsors greatest on itunes share with
your friends and let us know in the
comments you know what your answers were
to some of these did anything kind of
spark something in you or resonate with
you that maybe like an aha moment you
had let us know in the comments we love
reading them and we will see you next
week love you bye
bye see you just cried stay it back